we have some space that's a good picture
though no because you know what it is is
then if you're sitting there then we
have to [ __ ] be like that it's it's a
constant angle thing it's definitely an
angle thing all right we going hey
what's going on is Bill Byrne it's time
for a very special edition of the Monday
morning podcast I didn't know when the
[ __ ] I'm gonna put this out probably
before Monday because my guest his
series is already three episodes in and
he was supposed to be on two weeks ago
and I completely spaced a big Hollywood
phony that I am and very fitting that he
came back again in the name of his show
was the return of the Mack as he's
returning to the podcast
ladies and gentlemen Joe McIntyre thank
you - sorry man oh it's okay I knowing
you I know that you were you felt you
feel bad about it so I can you made me
feel worse because you were a [ __ ]
sweetheart about oh I was going like Joe
can you least get mad at me like I was
fine I needed because I needed to get
out of the house yeah says that no I was
I was hanging it was all good dude it
was all good and thank you thank you and
I know I know that you know I'm that you
don't have a lot of guests you know what
I mean so it's special so thank you for
Vedas I'm [ __ ] guilt trip dude do you
not see your wife this is brutal
I know you know you're gonna be looking
at people and it's it's kind of a Boston
thing too you know what I mean cuz we're
good with the guilt thing you know what
I mean so we can we can just let that
thing hang over your head forever you
know what I mean for years and years and
years but end up or no I'll do that
because I wouldn't have seen your show
exactly cuz I was you know I was busy
doing a bunch of [ __ ] right and then I'm
sitting there and I had like a panic
attack I'm like oh my god like I [ __ ]
stood this guy up I said wasn't be that
I wasn't then I go now I gotta watch
your shows like what if I don't like it
oh how [ __ ] brutal is this like half
hour 45 minutes gonna be fortunately I
watched it and it's [ __ ] hilarious
man Thank You Man
really funny q thank you thing I know I
I've got a few friends that said that
like ooh what am I gonna save I don't
like it but uh it is good it is good you
know when you you make something you
kind of all in it and to get some
perspective and actually see it on a
you know a TV and it's it's nice I feel
certain a lot of you know it's a sense
of accomplishment and what what I
couldn't find what network is it on
because weird the thing so it's on it's
on pop TV it's not on the comfy Channel
no I'm a comfy chair that's the channel
within the show yeah um yeah it's on pop
TV which is it's a CBS Lionsgate
partnership but it's it's the channels
been up for about two years
um it's on most I think every carrier
has it sometimes it's on like a you know
a higher tier so it's not basic which is
kind of a bummer sometimes so you know
on one sense you know there's not a ton
of expectation you know I mean and you
can build and hopefully the network's
like I will wait you know it's gonna
it's gonna build it takes a second um
but I'm crazy though I'm like you know
we were coming up there was just you
could find shows yeah now it's like do
you know my parents my parents have
never seen my show because it's on
Netflix and they don't know how to get
on it and somebody you gotta have a
password yeah you got to like grab the
other remote control do this yeah they
have no idea um that's why when I take
my specials they come to the special
because I know they're not going to be
able to find it once it gets on Netflix
it just you know that's the only way
they see it um I do I do tweet you I
mean I do text you when I see that
beautiful mug of you on on Billboard's
across Los Angeles and then you treat me
a picture of me and like Big Bopper and
in 1988 you don't I mean just to get
members you always give me [ __ ] though
yeah well you know I got away you know
you go we get it you got a special was
that [ __ ] haha that's the way you come
at me which is why I was surprised when
I when I didn't show up uh that you were
still uh so he's uh going back how I
originally met Joe was we worked on a
movie called the heat yes believe it or
not that was up coming up on five years
ago already we filmed it five years ago
and we had a great time on that and
another one of your cast members uh
Jenny Denbo was on that thing yep no one
returned to the Mack yes um we that was
that was sweet I mean that gig was sweet
Paul fake movie big movie you're in our
hometown
I said to Nate Corddry who's in it as
well
recently I said it's known as three
weeks in August like that that's it it
has its own name you know it was just a
line or thing yeah it was lovely it was
a lovely experience and obviously when
do you leave Boston um well I was in New
York for a while you know I I realized
after new kids broke up you know I woke
up when I was like 21 and I was like the
biggest decision I had to make was where
I was having lunch and I was like okay I
get it I got to do something
yeah I mean like and uh wait that that
whole thing broke up you took the whole
ride and was done by the time you were
21 oh yeah yeah I mean I was 15 when we
had our first hit record so that was
like 88 and then we had like you know
four or five years and then Kurt Cobain
came along and it was on that was it
it was all so much weirdoes then it
started back up again yeah in the late
nineteen thousand eight well you know
what Kurt killed himself
yeah isn't there to stop those boy back
then okay yeah exactly
oh no we wait yeah we've been back
together since 2008 but our fans have
grown up you know what I mean we we look
back on that but you know with with an
open heart and the nostalgia and all
that stuff when we embrace it and right
now we're just like a girls night out
for our fans you know they get to get
away from it but yeah you kind of touch
on that on the show where I noticed that
you have like you keep having these
really awkward moments where these like
with that overly like yeah next up women
you know yeah question oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah fifty years yeah that's true
does that happen to you a lot like they
want to give you a long a little too
long of a hug
I don't want you to [ __ ] on your fans
about yeah yeah yeah we have all you
know shapes and sizes there's a few
there's a few that did you something get
running for office yeah yeah I gotta get
in trouble in this while they're going
to me you know they're yeah you can't
blame me that we're still playing arenas
so like you say I got no I'm gonna take
care of my my fans absolutely I say the
right thing but no some some are a
little too little too uh you know
aggressive or you know touchy feely you
know I mean but that's okay for the most
part they're they're part of the job
right yes but but I so so I left so I
spent some time in New York and then
I've been out in LA for
fifteen years and are kind of getting
itchy for the to go back to go back east
dude you know it's it's the best here
but it's funny when I when I think of my
friends who are that you know have
babies you get you know you get how old
you get a little five three months three
months okay little over three and it's
hopeful you know what I mean it's really
funny is like in you know not to get all
you know it's a tough time in the world
and it's crazy whatever but and it's so
cliche but it's like really hopeful if
someone has a baby yeah because for you
it's all about that kid man
yeah I mean what's more hopeful than a
new kid you know you're just like you
know and it's and it's really nice I my
kids are yeah almost six seven and nine
so it's a little bit of a different vibe
right anyway some I don't know we feel
like you know what I feel like weird
about how once I left all of a sudden
they all to every team starts winning
championships but is so much fun it is
to be behind any enemy lines like
Celtics beat the Lakers I was out here
in Red Sox beat the Yankees I was in New
York but you know I recently did a show
and an acting gig actually one day back
in um in Boston and I remember the
Bruins would just start in the playoffs
and was looking at my hotel window and I
just saw a sea of Bruins jerseys and
just to finally be like oh my god I
could actually wear because I don't wear
any my [ __ ] out here just people had
nuts on the west coast okay they take it
to a whole other level it's it's it's
violent yeah it's not fun like when I
was in New York was fun it was ball
breaking I haven't been in Philly and
you know as much as they hike those guys
up it's like you got to go out of your
way to really get an asking you're
definitely going to get [ __ ] you might
get something dumped on you but that's
as far as it goes but out here yeah it's
just like it's like Mad Max yeah you're
a little scared for your life yeah I
mean I was at the 2010 when the when the
Lakers did beat the Celtics and I was
only called 58 fouls on the Celtics and
like 12 on that's that's great that's
great for a game seven yes fun to watch
the Lakers beat us from the foul line
that's a way that's always good for hoop
and they barely won you're right even
without our Center but I'm not saying we
would have won but I'm just saying it's
like you gotta let you gotta let them
play land let them [ __ ] play what's
most
anticlimactic than the one memorable
moment from that game that I can only
remember was Ron Artest hitting at 3
that was a [ __ ] huge shot yeah but and
it was ugly other than that it was an
ugly game yes there was no magic with
the baby skyhook there was always like a
moment bird steals the ball is something
like that was like nah they just uh
Kobe didn't have a good game that game
you know I'm not saying after the game
is like I kid I don't know how we won
that game it's like both [ __ ] talked
to the footlocker guys cuz those those
are MVPs they switched out the
footlocker guys'd it you know there
wouldn't have rubbed them the last
Boston Cleveland game not Cleveland game
sorry who the [ __ ] are we playing Bulls
the Bulls yeah now the last last Bulls
game like I thought the officiating was
terrible and it was in our favor and I
loved when Lopez did this like that
sarcastic oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was when you then you saw then they
went down the court and Dwyane Wade got
a ticky tack another one and he was like
laughing going like no one it was like a
make up call but it was like too late at
that point so right right all right um
good Sarah I mean we got the luck of the
draw there with Rondo getting hurt so no
the MVP the series I think even cuz even
still yeah cuz oh because he's still the
most valuable because he's because the
first her game it look like they were
gonna sweep us and all of a sudden it
was gone I know I know that he was in
his out you think he is I think that
he's gonna make six games fast is off
okay he's got long sleeves on his sport
coat again i trippin anybody you see him
trip uh uh what's his name crowd him
Crowder thank you I love when he tried
to act like he was stretch and he was
totally like looking right at him I
thought it was funny and then he says in
the press comedy yeah I got a CL and I
just like to stretch it next question
and he was twenty five thousand dollar
he goes he was really way out of bounds
he tried to put on him yeah yeah back
dad
deadpan face I actually I liked I
thought it was funny it was not I mean I
don't give a [ __ ] I see when a guy was
gonna break his [ __ ] leg over that he
sort of stuck it out he he's the kind of
guy you want on your team but he's not
on our team anymore right and and then
he tried to push you know Ray Allen out
of the big did he did you see that story
where did they haven't like a reunion a
ten-year reunion for the Celtics but
like a year earlier or something like
that they're all
the Bahamas or something like that and
they didn't invite Ray Allen because he
went to the Miami Heat
you know sometimes I never understood
that too because it was like him going
to Miami Miami Heat that's how we got
him he was a sonic yeah right yeah so if
you sign a free agent like and you it's
like I've joked to my pockets that's
like falling in love with a stripper
yeah there's no loyalty at that point
it's just like [ __ ] I'm gonna get
paid and try to win rings and he he what
was he that he was there three four
years I mean it just to me it's a
personality thing that's what I love
about sports the most like you can talk
about the X's and O's and all that stuff
but like the personalities man I mean
you look at LeBron like for me the way
it is and how they sit and why they sit
and why they rest and should they you
know they getting paid millions and
millions and millions of dollars in
there sitting there resting it's like oh
well they're tired well the other team's
tired too
you know so it's a it I just love that I
just think he's like LeBron is I call
him the greatest player ever to not want
the ball at the end of the game know
that was him before before they want it
well know anybody he's on the hill
doesn't want the ball at the end so I'm
not saying he's not amazing he does not
want the ball at the end of the game I
Kyrie Irving does I thought he pushed
through that when he was with the heat
he won he won if he can do that he won
he won I am a man don't yeah but he just
yeah it's a it's it I you know it's I'm
not hating on him I think he's an
amazing you know athlete in person and
all that stuff
I just think East he does it all the
greats Larry Bird Isiah Thomas
Kobe and all those Jordan of course they
wanted the ball everyone get out of my
way that's not him and it's it's it's
intriguing to me yeah I thought he was
that until like uh once he wanted with
the heat and all of a sudden a member he
was playing some game was the end of the
game and he actually took the shot and
missed but the fact that he did it I
thought that he pushed through you got
my two he came into the league at 18 I
just think it was all this expectation
that type of thing I think it took him a
minute yet to kind of grow into it but I
think I think he's he's past it then you
take the last friggin shot
to win it last year no that wasn't it no
no he ran down he blocked the ball no I
meant exactly but that's what he'll do
well that was he supposed to take a
whole court no no but he overcompensates
in these superhuman ways with that block
but it does not want the ball I've never
seen a guy so good get so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know what it is well some
people might think I'm hating on him I'm
saying you just called one of the
greatest defensive plays and when the
biggest moment of the biggest [ __ ]
game yes as underdogs he turns it on you
said it was overcompensating I'm not
well he that's hating a little bit I'm
know he makes up for not wanting the
ball at the end of the game I can't
listen if he takes the ball and gets it
on the buzzer beater I'll be thrilled
I'll be thrilled I'm not hating I'm not
saying he's not capable you won't be
thrilled if he does against the Celtics
you wouldn't be to me it's fascinating
that someone that talented still has
room to grow or our stuff they haven't
done all right that's son of Aaron uh-oh
hey Joe back to my TV show back to you
now I'm sure I'm getting it kidding how
much of that is improv uh not a lot
actually no no it's not right thank you
yeah i co-created it with my friend Paul
Greenberg who I was introduced to by
Donnie Wahlberg and Jenny McCarthy who
were also on the show oh yes Larry oh
yes yes they're executive producers as
well so Paul and I and then there was
Heather Rutman and Mike Glock our
writers and so it was a small writing
team but you know you have three days to
shoot so you don't really have a lot of
for each episode
wait you shoot that in three days three
days about how many so can we do two
episodes at a time so it's over six days
we do two episodes so yeah we have uh do
we have three no we had two cameras it
to me and I'm how long are your days not
super long because that gets into
overtime and that's a budget thing too
but I've learned a lot it's not he's
doing it right yeah so how was it take
you to shoot six uh so us Oh six you
mean six episodes well we did eight
episodes today so was uh three it was 24
days it was 20
four days and uh which is I I love it I
mean that's [ __ ] great you want more
you know be nice to have you know more
money you say oh it's fine and I want
more but like maybe if there's a second
season you want a little bit more dough
to do this so to do that but as far as
an actor and getting out there you don't
need that much time you know you have
four or five - I never felt like we
didn't have enough time to get the takes
but your point about you know at you
know ad-libbing or improving we didn't
have a lot of time to just go there so
the scripts were good I grade I was
really happy with them and and um you
know it is a little bit here and there
but for the most part I was scripted
yeah yeah that's the way to do a show
I've been worked with a few people that
knew like the only Sonny guys those guys
like you ever seen how they they'll
shoot this season like they have it all
mapped out so they'll like do for like
the whole season like all the bar things
and they're just there yeah shoot it all
run out change and they just do like
it's genius how they do it and then
there's other shows that you go on and
it's just like you're doing like 14 16
hour days and like you literally want to
kill III know show ya paint dry yeah and
I was just like I don't think I ever
want another acting gig in my life this
is [ __ ] horrific and I always called
like those types of shoots like people
say one of those things like I've said
compared it's like going to the DMV with
like famous people so he's just sitting
around the same thing just sitting there
thinking you're never gonna get called
and then when you finally do you're
[ __ ] elated and I don't know I've
heard like stories of like actors like
learning how to play instruments just
sitting and waiting in there yeah and it
yeah and I know it's like yeah you hate
to complain about a gig but it's true
you're in it you're in a you're in a
trailer and you're in your sights same
thing it's like this is what I work for
like this is what I want and and it's
not a win tonight or work like I want to
get there and work exactly for some
[ __ ] reason sitting around in its
itch I actually understood my dog better
like I get why when my dog is just
laying there it goes to sleep cuz your
body's like I well we're not doing [ __ ]
yeah let's save up this energy the end
you start nodding off like an old man
and the second you start to sleep you're
going to get that knock on your door now
you fell asleep you're not going to be
[ __ ] in it
they bring you our goal but we have a
quick we're losing light yeah I like it
yes it's it's more like a mentally look
it's way better than [ __ ] roofing in
June and July
exactly I lasted like three weeks doing
that [ __ ] but I just say like um you
know it is to me it's the frustration is
when you're there it's like it doesn't
have to take this [ __ ] long yeah no
it doesn't but that's you know what you
doing it doesn't have to take this
[ __ ] long fighting stuff and
everything and I guess you can't see the
difference in some you know the
production value and and that's fine but
I I agree sand and that's why it's it's
in my nature to go you know what I mean
I I got lucky a lot of people trying to
make TV shows in this town and like I'm
super grateful but like I I was like I
wanted to get active and do it and we
were able to get it done and yeah but
word gets out that you know people see
how funny a show is and that you guys
shoot it that quick yeah I don't think
you'll have a problem getting people
doing guest oh I think so I think so I'm
gonna quote your bill there you go you
just set yourself up and Plus you think
I don't know what I did there it is you
know what see you're shrewd businessman
you waited and Adam to kill Adam loves
you by the way Adam ray uh as so many do
but he was on the you you guys just did
a charity gig and he went on before you
and I think you were like this guy you
know you were very covered like this guy
should have closed what am i doing miss
Gazeta that was he go with April
foolishness exactly exactly yeah exactly
so yeah he [ __ ] murdered yeah he's
he's he was a it's one of those things
we say i I wrote for that person like
when I wrote the the the first pilot
like I was just writing for him you know
what I mean I was just getting off on on
his whole vibe he's super charming guy
loves I mean works a ton and and and we
had a blast doing good you guest stars -
I saw that like the third episode Joey
Fatone joy if it's a murder yeah yeah
yeah man he's he's a funny bastard so I
Danny I dearly silly doesn't he doesn't
like it just exactly self-deprecating ah
and then the Crisco Patrick who's also
from NSYNC he comes in at the end of
episode three and he he really throws
himself under the bus you know normally
you have a guest star in
and you gotta let them win you know what
I mean yeah but he comes up in Episode
five and he really you know goes for it
so I said you have all these guys on it
and it's great cuz that you let him do
what they're gonna do so you get to see
how town like Joey Lawrence murdered it
yeah I know he was great again again
yeah he's sort of like America's
Sweetheart but I knew a different side
of him a real ballbuster like acerbic
super funny he's super talented been
around forever but I knew when we went
at it you know doing that thing it would
be you know super funny and he was great
we had a blast doing it too so now is
that true did you guys both come in
third place we did we did so the thing
is I I want people most a lot of people
forget cuz I did the first season of
Dancing with the Stars and I didn't want
to do it man I wanted to be by take me
through that okay you're sitting there
you need a gig this is like an episode
of your show and your aging goes up by
Jo totally I got a guy got it yeah so it
was just after pilot season actually I
just did six months on Broadway in
wicked very early on with idina menzel
like you know excite of like what I what
I love to be doing but I had it in my
mind like a rookie I'm gonna go out it
to LA and book a pilot right just to
book a pilot just for my ego not because
of the work not because of the right
project you know what I mean so I was in
it for the wrong reasons was opal open
to uh seeing you for stuff yeah I mean
about a year or so before that I was on
a David Kelly show as a regular on
Boston Public that lasted for about
three years I was on it for a year it
changed my life I came out to LA I met
my wife so think safley like you needed
you needed you had to get one of those
gigs to separate you from all this guys
and a band a band the whole thing and I
just thought it would you know change my
life or whatever I'd be cool my ego it's
just I thought that was it it was nice
miss and so I had a bad you know pilot
season as you know so many wives do you
know what I mean everybody does know I
don't yeah now I know everybody no
matter how good you are you know what I
mean like it's a it's it's a crapshoot
so I get this call for dancer this
British guys like it's a beautiful it's
unbeliev
bullets it had some other name in the UK
and it's gonna be great and you know
don't worry you'll win and that whole
thing and and we want to make you look
bad yeah I was like great for your
career exactly and I was like I said no
a million times and then I said yes and
no and yes and no and literally I'm up
in my bed over how long a period of time
is all these males and yes maybe a week
or two so yeah and eyes are no agonising
right cuz this is not what I want to do
I don't want to do a reality show we
didn't know what Dancing with the Stars
and it's all relative some people I talk
about this and they go what's wrong with
it it stands in with the stars it's it's
the biggest show on TV but to each his
own you know that's not what I wanted to
do but anyways I I was up in bed I was
like after I almost like Sonic on track
I was like I can't do it because I was
in you know the joke is like I get up in
bed and I'm like I'm in a dance contest
with Evander Holyfield but what the [ __ ]
am i doing
what am i doing and and I just couldn't
say no and house was on that season uh
Rachel Hunter um whatever John O'Hurley
John O'Hurley from J Peterman we talked
about that in my show in Episode two and
uh another girl from General Hospital
and I'm blanking so sorry we're all they
were all a mess I was a dancer uh-huh so
they had to take me down it's a produced
show so they're gonna cut me out at the
knees from day one to get the storylines
going you know what it means oh wait so
I went how did they take you out on the
show so all these people all the dances
you can this what the [ __ ] you've been
doing your whole life Joey that was
awful you look like it's got me
surrounding a rally dance floor this is
oh yeah yeah they they murdered me they
murdered me and I didn't ask
yeah so now how did you hold your can
put like like you're standing there
they're filming go to the tape I mean
right now but yeah are you sitting I
like these my [ __ ] I don't want you
to try on but oh no I don't care I don't
care all right at this point I mean it's
a joke now I'm and that's why I was able
to use it in the show like they got like
a scud miss yeah yeah yeah literally
said and so you know I I'm I'm attached
from it now and and and I'm able to use
that stuff for my show like the guy I
play on my show now return the Mack is
is is that guy you know what I mean who
couldn't say no who didn't have the
patience or the integrity or the
discipline to ride it out for the right
part now that's why I like watching your
show cuz I see this other side like your
home life and stuff yeah even you get in
like the the person to help with your
kids yeah yeah yeah yeah and that [ __ ]
that I do i oh honey whoever you whoever
you wanted I fine that's right fortune
you know that's worked out in my life
yeah I mean yeah exactly until until you
know you get some crazy guy and then you
way indefinitely until till your wife
gets it wrong yeah whatever you need
until what the hell were you thinking
you know um but I interrupted a great
source of you know so you're sitting
there they're saying you like a scud
missile all over the place
I just didn't want to do the show but I
it was six episodes people still go
why don't you do Dancing with the Stars
and I think to myself should I tell him
I did it whatever cuz like it right my
ego says I like when people forget that
I did that show cuz it's not really what
I wanted to do right on the other side
it's like hey it's all showbiz right and
in life things happen and you learn from
them how many how many weeks did you do
well it was only six weeks back then cuz
it was the it was a summer program they
were given in a shot by six weeks the
finale there was like 15 million people
watching it so um and 15 million people
saw you come in third yes did you lose
to Evander Holyfield he know I beat
Evander Holyfield a yeah was a lot of
people say that that yeah off man but
just but but but but
exactly exactly but John John O'Hurley
loved it guys in his 60s he's doing the
walls he's eating it up they're loving
and he's eating the scenery you know
what I mean like god bless him this was
obsessing a spark in your eyes I haven't
seen in years exactly it was brilliant
and good for him you know what I mean he
had a blast and and I learned a lot too
I mean I learned you know how to do that
kind of dancing and you learn from the
dancers and dancers in this business
especially on Broadway
are the hardest-working people in show
business because they got a dance
you know most of them have to sing on
Broadway they dance and sing their egos
are like totally in check they they come
to work every day they don't complain
and it's the stars and the leads that
you know do all the complaining when
they really have it's so much better
than everybody else
right yeah Wow yeah so what was the
fallout of that so after that uh you
coming how did you take me we relieved
when he got kicked off the show at that
point we just I was kinda I think I got
episode 5 I was gone and then they had
me back for the finale everybody was
there for the finale um you know III
felt like I went out you know I I was
good with my performances but again they
they took me down because they needed a
storyline I mean that's kind of what
that that's my story anyways but um it
was cool I mean I actually did a
standards album after that and we went
on tour and we I feel like I got a
little something out of it you know to
me we weren't on like an arena tour and
funny enough that actually that's how I
met the new kids manager at the time we
were managing and I talked to Donnie
Donnie and I were talking about getting
together and I said well this might be
the manager because I've been working
with this guy so it's that kind of thing
you do things that you think I'm right
but you're there you make the most of it
and it could lead to bigger that led to
you guys getting back together well a
small piece a lot of things have to
happen you know what I mean stop nervous
we you would putting that thing back
together like going [ __ ] of 40 people
gonna show up yeah well the cool thing
was that we were we were in it together
I mean if we were if these other four
guys were willing to get in the foxhole
and see what happens because we have so
much history together and we're like
family you know what I mean so that was
a cool part you know what I mean and I
trusted those guys I mean Donnie you
know I felt like he always held our what
we had very dear to woman like when when
MTV or vh1 would go come on our
challenge come on our awards show they
wanted their big ratings hit they wanted
their five minutes and we always like
hey man we're bigger than five minutes
you know what I mean and sure enough the
timing was right and we did it the right
way and our fans showed up for us and
you know we back in arenas after you
know tell you guys didn't even wait
- right you'll be doing Fenway Park July
8th again I don't it again yeah cool
yeah so cool that's great cool that's
right so we got you got five more
episodes coming out yeah
so you're gonna get back to Boston uh
what's your deal man are you gonna like
stay out here uh the show now I know
well we'll see we'll see about the you
know second season you know how that
goes but um I don't know I don't know if
I'm just distracting myself by saying I
want to like get back to New York or
Boston
it's so nice out here you actually have
like a yard you know I mean in New York
it's just a totally different thing my
wife's from New York but it's high-class
problems but I'm just kind of like I
don't know if I'm just need something to
chew on you know what I mean or if I'm
like do relax you know I mean just
you're here be where you are you know
that right rather than getting all
[ __ ] antsy yeah that's definitely a
UH that's definitely a shoe I have like
my wife freaks out about that just going
like can you just sit down yeah and
watch TV with you and then if I watch TV
it becomes interactive and I'm like
talking to it and she's just like you're
ruining all of my show and you have to
live I mean that's yeah I
she's like shut up or leave the room
because I can get very you know like
Parenthood she loved Parenthood mm-hmm
and I get it was a very successful show
but like you know I would yeah I would
tear it apart yeah like you mean that's
all I do she goes my wife I she's
actually come on the podcast cuz she
kind of went rogue on me you know
there's just there's a rule with like
recording shows yeah we're this the hey
I take the game you don't give a [ __ ]
hey you've got the Real Housewives so
who gives a [ __ ] I don't care but the
good shows the far goes the better call
Saul's we got your show right now it's
like you know these are the other shows
but what this is like with the kid this
is like our shared family time right
dude she watched a better call Saul
[ __ ] erase the thing yeah and then
tries to go all you can go on to
wherever Wow yeah and I went Wow
yes that's know be discussing that's not
oh you're bringing her in for that one
yeah I was just sitting there going like
way down yeah like let's go
honest Sara somebody else you see in
here huh what's good I thought this was
like a together thing that's how it
starts
that's how it started stereos your first
hint that there's a problem we have
marriages the shows you used to watch
together all of a sudden it's just like
like did you just stop taping that did
you wanna know that was up sideways the
Fargo one
she watched like the first episode of
the second episode and she just erased
is it a mistake was it because it was
like the lowest priority thing no no no
it was she has gone rogue she is in TV
yeah
and I love that you have in that
reaction cuz this is prime and the pump
for the next yeah that we might call the
next episode I'm with ya Wow Wow my wife
wow that's so that that's why I was
looking at it's like so that's how it is
yeah how it is I guess I'm on my own now
said the baby thing is it the like she's
you know kind of you know she kind of
said it was that she was just like look
you go out in the road you're doing your
gigs yes just like I'm home here I'm
fried yeah okay I need to look at some
adults can only go googoo gaga so long
and I am so sleep-deprived when you're
not here
oh you know I just you know delete yes
yeah you know robot mode in dead oh did
I die I die right [ __ ] whatever go on
Netflix and find it you're out there
gettin eight hours sleep that's how she
looks at it so anyways so let's let's
get the schedule here okay you got you
can where can they people watch wall
picket right now it's just it's I wish
you know we were on some other you know
uh what do you call the Netflix in the
hole to see Souls II know what are you
say that the Amazon not yet right now
cuz it's a it's a it's it's own channel
so we want to get people to you know go
to pop but it's it's it's pop TV you can
go to poptv.com and throw in your zip
code if you want to find out what your
channel is but it's it's basic for a lot
of them sometimes it's a higher tier so
unfortunately you got it you might have
to dig a little bit but it's on pop TV a
lot of people have it it's on all the
carriers
good night what nights Wednesdays at
8:30 on pop TV and for for another five
episodes and so to get people caught up
yeah he's trying to make a move they
hitch him a talk show yeah you don't
want to do
would ya people get in your head yeah
now you're doing it I have and I do and
it people made no major decisions
without without your event that seems to
be a running theme I'm glad I was in on
that pulling the rug out from under me
at every every moment yes we got your
psychic and now all caught up and now
they've decided that it's not gonna be a
comedy no and now they're gonna go mad
honey
she tells me I love get the idea the
reason why it's we got it now I figured
it out and up you're not funny I like to
say up being like going on stage and
like deliberately bombings hard yeah
yeah you've been like could you just
automatically have to save her like well
that didn't work it's at least giving
chuckle I dye my pink I did that thing
about pixie sticks I don't know for some
reason it was just that thing like you
know that that line you know people have
an idea of what stand-up is and yeah go
twos and for some reason mine was
remember Pixy Stix
yeah what's up what is stupid like and
you think it's gonna be funny and it's
not so I just love oh never had a payoff
I mean not does anybody need that much
sugar yeah it's just one setup after
another and you just can't [ __ ] go
with it is this like oh my god I've
literally been that gum oh that is that
is people's ideas stay everybody has
like got the ideas of the boy band
thinking oh it's just that the other
thing act then when they see the actual
work of it so right right Joey
thank you all great to have you man I
really hope I get to work again I was
great to get to know you on the heat
once again I I apologize for wrong I'm
gonna use it for all it's worth belt it
worked out this this here this episode
wonderful return of the Mack thank you
for coming in and continued success with
a great show you too alright